it's gonna be fun it's gonna be good  a little nervous a little worried I  don't bake whatsoever the judges are  kids so I know my audience  nice to meet you have you eaten a star  before yes oh you did so what does  magical water look like colorful way out  of my comfort zone gonna take some risks  today things could go wrong I'm feeling  so much pressure right now I'm scared  here we go here goes nothing  foreign  I've never used one of these before it's  always a great thing to say it's looking  good I think that looks good look at  that that looks radioactive hope this  was a good idea  [Music]  let's go let's do it  May the best astronaut win  [Music]